this kept pictures coming in from
Quentin Jenelle is believed to be near
the maelbeek metro station this is
people going down into the tunnel to try
to help people down there it's it's the
terror that it causes amongst people
watching these images that the
terrorists want to see isn't it that
that we're succeeding in the sense of a
broadcast in these pictures so being
shown across the world we're all looking
at them and we're all quite frankly
feeling quite terrified about going out
and public transport well that's right
but only on the other hand of course it
means that people will be alert will be
looking out for things will tend now to
report anything that they deem
suspicious so there is an upside to
publishing these sort of images but yes
they're very terrifying I remember
talking to a police officer at 7-7 who
was on his way to a course dressed in
plain clothes and he actually went he's
made his way through the police cordons
because of his warrant Cartman actually
got down and was helping people in one
of these trains that was bombed and it
was very very traumatic for him very
brave of him but very traumatic for him
to go down there and see this sort of
scene but probably worse because you've
got people trapped in stations who are
in agony who are crying out for help
you have to triage them you have to look
who can I save who can I help who is
beyond help
so very very difficult for those first
on the scene not to remember that
officers account vividly